[Applause]
money isn't everything it is when you
haven't got it
yes money was everything in the gilded
age well as long as it was the right
kind of money
hello i'm alicia malone i'm a host on
turner classic movies and that means i
know a lot about film history but
american history i mean with this accent
not so much but that's where my co-host
comes in i love your accent hi i'm tom
myers i'm from the bowery boys history
podcast which is all about new york city
history
including that exciting time in the late
19th century that we call the gilded age
well this the gilded age is a new hbo
original series created by julian
fellowes and it's a drama that's set in
late 1800s new york where a social war
is raging between new money and old and
after each episode you can join us as we
discuss what happened on the screen and
also discuss how the show incorporates
real people and places and events from
new york in the 1880s because so many of
the things that we're going to see on
the show really happened the power
struggles within new york's high society
but also changes that took place in the
city changes in transportation and
technology even changing tastes in
architecture
we're going to be going inside some
really lavish mansions
oh yeah and we get to see some lavish
dinner parties the food
and those really happen too i'm sure oh
yes i did and you'd better watch your
manners alicia because mrs astra is
watching oh no uh well
we'll also be joined by some of the cast
and crew who bring the show to life the
directors and the costume designers and
more with exclusive behind-the-scenes
interviews and fun-filled history our
new podcast will be the ultimate look
inside the new series and inside the
gilded age itself this is a great city
in a great country at a great time in
our history
and to be part of it and you can be part
of it if you subscribe now to the
official gilded age podcast our first
podcast episode becomes available after
the series premiere on hbo and hbo max
on monday january 24th
[Music]
you